astérix a présenté hier à la presse son
plan d' attaques de l'oise
un nouveau parc de loisirs qui ouvrira
ses portes dans un an à 38 km de paris
suit aux environs de la capitale la
concurrence s'annonce sévère entre les
différents centres de loisirs le parc
astérix n'a pourtant pas d'inquiétude
une bonne partie des billets est déjà
vendu 800 millions en investissement 2
millions 600 mille visiteurs par an
prévus en régime de croisière plus de
100 points d'animations pour un prix
unique journalier de 120 francs par
adulte
le parc astérix dont l'ouverture est
prévue pour le printemps 1989 est déjà
fort avancée sur les six mondes
différents
conçu autour d'un thème central le petit
personnage de bd cher à goscinny et
uderzo déjà le village gaulois et le
delphinarium sont quasiment achevés
de quoi ravir les pères spirituels du
projet c'est l'apothéose parce que
on ne pouvait jamais on ne sera jamais
imaginé avec magazine est qu'un jour ce
personnage portrait la thématisation
d'un parc de loisirs d'ailleurs on était
loin de penser les palais royaux en
france à ce jour
premier parc à thème français
d'envergure européenne
le parc astérix avec ses 2 100 emplois
permanents et ses 1000 emplois
saisonniers risque de devenir à terme un
atout économique touristique d'envergure
pour la région